hygiene skandal gammelfleisch ungesunde
zusätze die fleischerei fritzer in calbe
will mehr transparenz bei wurst workshop
erfahren die kunden genau was reinkommt
[Musik]
hier haben wir die schlacht helfen und
lassen hier reichen die reifen im
schnitt 14 tage so jetzt haben wir jetzt
zwei auf leicht zurecht gestellt
wir machen eine feine bratwurst eine
gewollte feine bratwurst und eine grobe
bratwurst
[Musik]
jetzt müssen wir das ganze pack fleisch
aus dem später grillwürstchen werden
sollen
ballen kneten ja es ist wichtig kinder
treten aktiviert das eiweiß und dort
kriegen wir eine bindung kranke morgen
auf die faust liebe hat dafür einerseits
um sich abzureagieren und man hat wenig
mehr kraft als mit der flachen hand
das ist handwerk was ist gutes fleisch
und wie erkennt man es maybritt wilkens
verkauft mit ihrem geschäftspartner
rinder über ihre online plattform besser
fleisch
[Musik]
der konsument soll eine beziehung zu
tier und fleisch bekommen
auf den zu starken zusammenhalt nicht
ganz so fest und möchte endlich zum
ersten mal machen
so ist das zocken wollen einfach zeigen
wie wir arbeiten und das gehört ja nicht
nur wir unsere webseite aussieht sondern
auch für unser schlachter arbeitet und
für uns aber arbeitet das heißt wir
möchten
solche tage anbieten damit eben die
transparenz auch wirklich besteht
den jungunternehmern geht es ums
tierwohl und um die transparenz bei der
fleisch herkunft
[Musik]
also im prinzip was wir machen ist so
ein kleines digitales dorf wir haben ein
rind wir haben verschiedene kunden und
die essen quasi das eine sind zusammen
auf das ist ja die traditionelle
fleischvermarkter also früher hat wenn
ein bauer eine ringschlacht wollte dann
hat sich das ganze dorf dieses
mitgeteilt dass rinder sharing heißt das
prinzip
mit dem das norddeutsche startup
erzeuger und kunden vernetzt
sie vermarkten jedes tier individuell
das fleisch kostet bei ihnen etwa so
viel wie im biomarkt aber ihre pakete
sind gemischt es gibt nicht nur die edel
teile auch das ist nachhaltiger
fleischkonsum
es geht um die wertschätzung des tieres
geht darum das tier auch wirklich erst
dann zu schlachten wenn wir wissen es
wird alles verbraucht und es kommt alles
bei den kunden haben nichts weggeworfen
das ist der ansatz doch wie kommt die
kuh ins internet zum digitalen dorf
gehört auch der bio bauer lukas
massenheim vom hof krumbeck er ist eine
der erzeuger für das start up
als studierte sinologin hatte maybrit
wilkens bis vor einem jahr nichts mit
landwirtschaft zu tun
doch sie störte sich zunehmend an der
massentierhaltung
so entstand die idee selbst in die
rinder vermarktung einzusteigen
also ich möchte einmal dass es dem tier
gut geht ich möchte dass das rind auf
der weide ist dass es gras fressen kann
das ist und daher lebt ich möchte dass
der bauherr bezahlt wird denn der bauer
braucht eben das geld um seine tiere
genauso zu halten und der kunde braucht
natürlich die transparenz weil sonst
glaubt man es nicht also die
fleischwirtschaft dass es schon so
undurchsichtig und wir wollen eben
zeigen wie die tiere leben damit am ende
auch der kunde bereit ist diese preis zu
bezahlen
tiere die auf der weide stehen dürfen
und nicht im stall mit kraftfutter
gemästet werden stehen in der
klimabilanz besser da ihr fleisch ist
auch gesünder und geschmackvolle wenn
ich meine tiere in den größeren anonymen
auch biomarkt liefere
dann ist da meistens nicht der platz um
zu zeigen wer dahinter steht und wer die
arbeit macht und wie er sie macht und
deswegen es ist für mich eigentlich ein
ideales modell ich kümmere mich um die
tiere und besser falsch wenn man sich
dann darum dass das fleisch auch zu den
leuten kommt und das ist eine super
zusammenarbeit passt mir genommen
richtig krank
die nachfrage steigt anfangs hat besser
fleisch ein rind pro monat im internet
angeboten mittlerweile sind es etwa zehn
tiere pro monat
von der bestellung ist das produkt und
zuhauses vergehen auch gut mal drei vier
wochen und das müssen die leute erst mal
verstehen ich dachte auch die erste zeit
doch jetzt vielleicht schwierig da die
kunden springen wieder ab aber ich merke
es genau das wollen die leute sie wollen
kein massenprodukt sie wollen warten und
sie wollen etwas ordentliches auf dem
teller haben von dem sie dürfen bisher
wissen was drin ist wissen wo es
herkommt fleischgenuss mitverantwortung
geht